[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
zohra
ok
et aux hommes
chn
mon sens
et
[Musique]
oui
chat
je
et
à temps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
do
on
[Musique]
le
de loin
[Musique]
chn
ce que je ça
[Musique]
jetons
quel
[Musique]
oui
sow
besson
m
[Musique]
jo
oui
m
[Musique]
sow
le jeu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
on
[Musique]
je
histoire
c
[Applaudissements]
mal
et
ça
c'est
à
[Applaudissements]
et ça
[Musique]
tu es
et ça
vva
c'est
ça
cher
je
[Musique]
monsieur
m
il a
[Musique]
merci je vais essayer de reprendre un
peu son souffle depuis tout aussi loin
que je m'en souvienne j'ai toujours été
toujours été animé par un désir
artistique étant petit voilà mes parents
ma famille pourrait vous leur
accompagnement du coin pardon je mentais
des spectacles de chants de danses des
mises en scène
il ya toujours une fibre l'intérieur ou
a besoin d'exprimer d'exprimer mes
émotions de parole de par le corps et
j'ai décidé du fait de faire de ma
passion mon métier je suis devenu
professeur dans ses danseurs
contemporains modern jazz etcetera
désolé ce qui me passionne
ce qui m'anime le plus dans dans le
métier que je fais c'est c'est la
rigueur que la danse nous nous oblige à
avoir avec une énorme dose de liberté
j'aime beaucoup l'improvisation j'étais
en impro pas mal de temps dans cette
présentation
pourquoi j'aime l'impro c'est qu'est-ce
que j'aurais envie de faire à l'instant
t qu'est ce qui va me venir dans le
corps ou ma curiosité m'emmène pour
pouvoir évoluer dans l'espace découvrir
de nouvelles choses
des nouveaux chemins corporels pour
ensuite le cérébralisé ans après qu'est
ce que ça m'a apporté de nouveau
d'anciens qui ce l'ancien qui ce qui se
commet pardon qui s'actualise merci
voilà où là où la nouveauté calais
qu'elle est dans ma recherche dans ma
curiosité dans l'improvisation quelle
liberté je peux trouver pour ensuite
l'intégrer dans une rigueur et pour moi
danser c'est une phrase qui dit danse et
ses êtres vivants c'est un petit peu
c'est un petit peu ce que je sais ce que
je ressens en ce sens que de par le
corps de par le mouvement on peut
exprimer toutes les émotions possibles
et imaginables qui nous qui nous
traversent
et c'est ce que j'avais envie de me
mettre à profit dans mon art devant vous
ou pas devant vous je règle générale
c'est ce qui me ce qui me pousse à me
lever tous les matins en tout cas je
vous remercie beaucoup pour votre
attention je vous souhaite une bonne
continuation
[Applaudissements]